♪ ♪
>> Laura: THAT IS
BOURBON STREET LIVE RIGHT NOW,
FAT TUESDAY.
BEGINS IN ABOUT ONE HOUR AND
10 MINUTES.
OUR OWN RAYMOND ARROYO,
NEW ORLEANS NATIVE, INSISTED,
TWISTED MY ARM THAT I GO WITH
THE BIG EASY RIDE THERE AND MY
FIRST MARDI GRAS PARADE.
IT WAS AN ADVENTURE, AND WE
WANTED TO BRING YOU ALL ALONG ON
THIS MARDI GRAS DAY.
CHECK IT OUT.
>> HAPPY MARDI GRAS!
♪ ♪
>> LAURA, MARDI GRAS BEGAN IN
1699 HERE WHEN JOHN BAPTISTE
LANDED A 60-MILE SOUTH OF
NEW ORLEANS, AND THEY CELEBRATED
THE FIRST MARDI GRAS HERE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY IN MOBILE,
ALABAMA, BUT VERY QUICKLY, ONCE
NEW ORLEANS WAS FOUNDED IN 1718,
THIS BECAME THE EPICENTER OF
MARDI GRAS.
♪ ♪
>> AS TIME WENT ON, THESE
MARDI GRAS CREWS GOT BIGGER AND
BIGGER, AND REMEMBER, THIS IS
NOT JUST ANY FESTIVAL.
THIS IS OUR PRELENT PREPARATION.
>> Laura: DEPRIVATION.
>> REMEMBER, THE OLD CATHOLIC
RIGHT, YOU COULDN'T DRINK IN THE
40 DAYS OF RENT, SO YOU HAD A
BLOWOUT FROM JANUARY 6TH TILL
ASH WEDNESDAY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
MARDI GRAS.
♪ ♪
>> WE HAVE TO WEAR COSTUMES,
LAURA.
>> Laura: THIS IS THE THING,
I'M FROM CONNECTICUT.
WE HAVE A MEMORIAL DAY PARADE,
GIRL SCOUTS, VETERANS.
>> IN NEW ORLEANS, THINGS ARE
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
EVERYBODY WHO PARADES IN A GROUP
HAS TO WEAR A COSTUME, AND YOU
MUST WEAR A MASK.
IT IS ACTUALLY AGAINST THE LAW
TO NOT MASK.
A PUT THEM ON.
HERE WE GO.
♪ ♪
>> ALL RIGHT, WE ARE ROLLING.
>> LET'S DO IT.
♪ ♪
>> BEFORE YOU LOAD ON THE
FLOATS, YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
ALL OF YOUR THROWS ARE READY.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: THIS IS GOING TO BE
REALLY FUN.
>> THE FLOAT WE ARE WRITING IS
THE LARGEST OF MARDI GRAS, SIX
SEPARATE CARS.
IT IS NOT AS EASY AS IT LOOKS.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, LAURA,
YOUR FIRST MARDI GRAS RIDE
PAIRED WITH IT LIKE?
>> Laura: IT'S COLD.
IT'S INCREDIBLE, WE HAVE ALREADY
MET GREAT FRIENDS, WE HAVE A LOT
OF NEW FRIENDS ON THE FLOAT,
EVERYONE IS DRINKING JUST WATER.
>> ONLY WATER.
♪ ♪
>> HAPPY MARDI GRAS!
LOOK AT THIS CROWD, LAURA.
UNBELIEVABLE.
♪ ♪
>> WE MADE IT IN ONE PIECE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, IT'S A LONG
DAY.
>> Laura: IT'S A LONG DAY, BUT
THE FACES, THE SMILES, THE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET, THAT MADE
IT.
IT WAS FANTASTIC.
EVERYBODY HAVE A HAPPY
MARDI GRAS!
>> Laura: OKAY, RAYMOND SAID
WE SHOULDN'T THROW ALL OF THE
GOOD DEEDS EARLY BECAUSE WE
WOULD RUN OUT.
WE GOT TO THE CONVENTION CENTER
WHERE ALL OF THE PEOPLE ARE, WE
HAD FOUR BAGS OF BEADS LEFT
OVER, AND WE HAD TO LEAVE THEM
BEHIND.
IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.